I remember the day my dad taught me how to shave. For him to take the time to instruct me about anything was so unusual that, even while we stood there at the sink, I thought I'd remember it. I wanted to remember it. I wanted it to mean something, like it was some sort of "boy becomes a man" rite of passage, though that kind of sentimentality is more my personality than my dad's. I doubt he felt anything of the kind.
我记得父亲教我刮胡子的那一天。他花时间教我任何事都是极其罕见的，以至于即使那时我们站在水槽旁，我也心想我会记住这一刻。我想要记住它。我希望它具有某种意义，仿佛那是某种“男孩成为男人”的成人礼，尽管这种感伤更多是我本人的个性，而非我父亲的。我怀疑他并没有感受到任何此类情绪。
I still think about it some mornings when I shave, decades later. I remember every part of his instructions-- that I had to wet my face down with hot water to soften the barely existent facial hair, which were not the kind of men's whiskers that needed softening. So I wondered if he knew what he was talking about. He showed me how to hold a razor, the length of the strokes.
几十年后的今天，当我清晨刮胡子时，我仍会想起那天。我记得他教导的每一个细节——我必须用热水打湿脸庞，软化那几乎不存在的胡须，那根本不需要软化。所以我怀疑他是否真的知道自己在说什么。他教我如何握住剃须刀，以及刮胡时的力度。
When it came time to demonstrate the actual shaving, he realized he couldn't actually do it from the front. He needed to stand behind me and then reach up to my face at the same angle that he was used to shaving his own face with. So he got in back of me and sort of reached his arms up around me, close and intimate while he did that, which was unusual. He was a conscientious dad, a worried dad, a caring dad, but we never had much physical contact.
当到了演示实际刮胡的环节时，他意识到他无法从正面操作。他需要站在我身后，以他习惯为自己刮脸的角度触碰我的脸。于是他站到我背后，双臂环绕着我，动作亲密而贴近，这很不寻常。他是一位负责任、忧心忡忡且充满关怀的父亲，但我们之间几乎没有过什么身体接触。
What stands out most about this memory is how few I have that are like it of him actually teaching me something, taking the time to impart some kind of lesson about the world. To get that kind of focused attention from him was rare. He grew up without a dad. And he did his best, but he didn't have much feeling for what a son might want or might get from a father. Day to day, his mind didn't seem to be on me or my sisters at all, but on his job. He was an accountant, stressed out, working long hours at the firm he started.
关于这段记忆，最突出的是我对他真正教我什么、花时间向我传授人生经验的记忆竟如此稀少。能得到他那种专注的关注是很难得的。他在没有父亲的环境下长大。他尽力了，但他并不太了解一个儿子可能想要什么，或者能从父亲那里得到什么。日复一日，他的心思似乎根本不在我和我姐妹身上，而是在他的工作上。他是一名会计师，总是压力重重，在他创立的公司里长时间工作。
Years ago, I was invited to contribute a short chapter to a book about what men learned from their dads. And I wrote something saying that this shaving memory is one of the few that I have of him passing on some kind of knowledge or wisdom. And I showed him the draft, worried that he would be hurt that I would think that or that I would say it publicly. But his biggest problem with what I wrote was that I called him an accountant. He was a CPA, he told me. Very different. Could I change it? Of course, I did.
多年前，我受邀为一本关于“男人从父亲那里学到了什么”的书写一个短篇章。我写道，这段刮胡子的记忆是我记忆中他传授给我某种知识或智慧的为数不多的时刻之一。我把草稿给他看，担心他会因为我的想法或公开这样说而感到受伤。但他对我所写内容最大的异议在于我称他为会计师。他告诉我，他是注册会计师（CPA）。这大不相同。我能改掉吗？我当然改了。
He died a few weeks ago, at 90 with dementia. It's weird watching somebody with your same body, your same roll of fat around their stomach, same hands, same fingers, same skin, go gray and stop breathing. Right. That's me, I thought. Soon enough. And I've been thinking a lot about the parts of him that I carry in me. My dad wasn't very curious about others. If he met you, he wouldn't ask you lots of questions to figure out who you are or how you tick. Wasn't the most talkative.
他几周前去世了，享年90岁，生前患有痴呆症。看着一个拥有和你相同身体、腹部有相同赘肉、同样的手、同样的指头、同样的皮肤的人，变得灰白并停止呼吸，这感觉很怪。对，我想，那也是我。很快就会轮到我了。我一直在思考我身上携带的那些属于他的特质。我父亲对他人不太好奇。如果他遇见你，他不会问你很多问题来弄清你是谁，或者你的性格如何。他不是最健谈的人。
If anything, some of the moves that I developed as an interviewer come directly from being in the car with him and trying to actually get him to speak about something, anything, which I guess happens a lot. Kids develop personalities to fit into the jigsaw pieces of what their parents aren't.
如果说有什么影响的话，我在采访时发展出的一些手段，直接源于和他一起待在车里时，为了让他开口谈论哪怕任何事情而尝试的方式，我想这种情况发生得很多。孩子们为了适应父母性格的缺失部分，会发展出自己的个性。
I honestly see his good traits in me and all of his bad ones, too, all the time. The biggest of those, some deep part of me that feels so much more comfortable when I'm alone than when I'm around other people. Sometimes all I want to be is alone and just not deal. That kind of thing isolated my dad from people who cared about him, from love and experiences that he could have had. And it's done that to me as well, at times.
我时常能在他身上看到我的优点，也能看到他所有的缺点。其中最主要的是，我内心深处总有一种感觉：比起与人相处，我独自一人时会感到更自在。有时我只想一个人待着，什么都不想应对。这种特质曾让我的父亲远离了那些关心他的人，错过了他本可以拥有的爱和经历。在某些时刻，它也对我造成了同样的影响。
When was the day he taught me that? I think most of what we learned from our parents, they never intended for us to learn. This stuff just shows up inside of us like a virus, one that they never meant to transmit and we didn't mean to catch. Then we look up later and they're in us, while we watch them on morphine, struggling with their breathing, and after they're gone, as well.
他教我的那天是哪一天？我想，我们从父母那里学到的东西，大多数并非他们刻意想要教给我们的。这些东西就像病毒一样出现在我们内心，一种他们从未打算传播、我们也从未打算感染的病毒。然后，当我们稍后回过神来，发现他们已在我们体内，这时我们正看着他们服用吗啡，在呼吸困难中挣扎，而在这之后，我们也依然携带着他们。
Today on our show, we have stories where kids grapple with their dad's legacies-- stuff about them consciously and unconsciously, good and bad, that they left behind. OK, for this next line, I have an old recording of my dad.
今天在我们的节目中，我们讲述的故事是关于孩子们如何面对父亲留下的遗产——那些他们有意无意间留给我们的、有好有坏的东西。好吧，接下来的这段录音是我父亲的老录音。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。
Dad, you are such a pro.
爸，你真是太专业了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
Stay with us.
请继续收听。
Act One, "Am I My Father's Trapper Keeper, Keeper?" Before we get to the father in this story, let me play you this ad. It's from the '80s. Two teenagers in a crowded library, they stand up and, oops, bump into each other. Papers fall to the ground.
第一幕，“我是我父亲的Trapper Keeper收集者吗？”在讲到这个故事里的父亲之前，先让我播一段广告。这来自80年代。两个青少年在拥挤的图书馆里，他们站起来，哎呀，撞到了对方。纸张掉到了地上。
Oh!
哦！
Sorry.
抱歉。
I'm sorry.
对不起。
Such good acting, then this realistic piece of dialogue.
如此好的演技，接着是这段写实的对白。
Here you are.
给你。
Oh, thank you.
哦，谢谢。
Say, what is that thing?
请问那是什么东西？
It's my Trapper from Mead.
那是我的Mead公司出的Trapper文件夹。
It sure is a lot neater than this.
它确实比这个整洁多了。
It's an ad for a Trapper Keeper notebook. One of the main selling points-- keeps all your papers trapped. Get it? So they don't fall out.
这是一个Trapper Keeper笔记本的广告。它的主要卖点之一——能把你的纸张全部“困住”。明白了吗？这样它们就不会掉出来。
And I've got a Trapper folder for each subject.
而且我为每个科目都准备了一个Trapper文件夹。
That's pretty neat.
那挺整洁的。
Mm-hmm. And the Trapper Keeper holds all my Trappers. This flap even has a Velcro closure to keep everything inside.
嗯。而Trapper Keeper可以装下我所有的Trapper。这个翻盖甚至还有魔术贴封口，可以把所有东西都锁在里面。
Boy, I've got to get a Trapper and get my act together.
天哪，我得买一个Trapper，把我的东西收拾好。
If you do, I'll let you carry my books.
如果你买了，我就让你帮我背书。
That last line kind of gets to me. What is wrong with me? Ads like this are the kind of thing that either evoke nostalgia or complete bafflement. But if you were around in the '80s, you knew the Trapper Keeper-- the Velcro sound when you open it, the pictures on the covers, the rings of the binder. They sort of smoothly slid open and shut instead of snapping so you wouldn't catch your fingers.
最后那句话触动了我。我这是怎么了？像这样的广告要么勾起怀旧之情，要么让人完全困惑。但如果你生活在80年代，你就知道Trapper Keeper——当你打开它时魔术贴的声音，封面上的图案，活页夹的圆环。它们滑动开合非常顺滑，而不是那种会夹到你手指的卡扣。
According to a press release from the time, half of all middle school and high school students had a Trapper Keeper in 1989. I don't know if I believe that, but there were a lot of them around. Anyway, when the inventor of the Trapper Keeper died last year, it got a lot of attention.
据当时的一份新闻稿称，1989年，一半的初中生和高中生都拥有Trapper Keeper。我不知道这是否可信，但当时确实到处都是。总之，当Trapper Keeper的发明者去年去世时，这引起了极大的关注。
E. Bryant Crutchfield, the inventor of the Trapper Keeper, has died.
Trapper Keeper的发明者E. Bryant Crutchfield去世了。
If you were in school during the 1980s or '90s, I'd be willing to bet good money you carried around the cultural phenomenon of a binder created by a man named E. Bryant Crutchfield.
如果你在80年代或90年代上学，我敢打赌你肯定用过那个由E. Bryant Crutchfield创造的文化现象级活页夹。
NPR, The Today Show, The Washington Post, The New York Times, they all ran stories. And then we got this email. It was from a woman who was very surprised by those obituaries. Because, as far as she knew, the inventor of the trapper keeper was very much alive. And he was her father.
NPR、今日秀、华盛顿邮报、纽约时报，他们都报道了这个新闻。然后我们收到了这封电子邮件。发件人是一位对这些讣告感到非常惊讶的女士。因为据她所知，Trapper Keeper的发明者还健在。而他正是她的父亲。
She said her dad had invented it, not the guy in the obit. And she was not happy about it. Obviously, this is not the kind of tip that a self-respecting radio producer can just let go. Phia Bennin, here on our program, tried to figure out what was going on.
她说，她的父亲发明了这个东西，而不是讣告里提到的那个人。她对此很不高兴。显然，这是一个有自尊心的广播制作人不能忽视的线索。我们节目的Phia Bennin试图弄清楚到底发生了什么。
The dad in the email, his name is Jon Wyant, lives in South Carolina. He's 83 years old. And I can definitely confirm he's alive. How do I know? I talked to him. He saw the obit when he was looking at his computer one day, and there, on the screen, was his old colleague, E. Bryant Crutchfield.
邮件里的那位父亲名叫Jon Wyant，住在南卡罗来纳州。他83岁了。我可以肯定他确实还活着。怎么知道的？我跟他谈过了。他有一天在电脑上看新闻时看到了这则讣告，屏幕上显示的竟是他以前的同事E. Bryant Crutchfield。
After I read it, I told my wife. I said, oh, well, poor Bryant, he's gone. But I just looked at it and thought, well, I know the truth. So what could I do? I mean, I was not about to sit down and write a rebuttal and send it to The New York Times.
我读完后告诉了妻子。我说，哦，好吧，可怜的Bryant，他走了。但我只是看着它心想，好吧，我知道真相。那我能做什么？我的意思是，我不可能坐下来写一封反驳信发给纽约时报。
How come?
为什么不呢？
Well, just not me.
嗯，我不是那种人。
The sense I get from talking to Jon is that he's someone who tucks his feelings away, sealed tightly, maybe with Velcro. Well, that is not true of the rest of his family. His daughter, Jackie, the one who wrote us, here's how she remembers obit day.
通过与Jon的交谈，我感觉他是一个习惯把情绪藏起来、封得紧紧的人，就像用魔术贴封住一样。嗯，他的家人可不这样。他的女儿Jackie，也就是写邮件给我们的那位，她是这样回忆讣告发布那一天的。
I was sitting in my kitchen and my phone rings, and my mom calls me. And she just said, you're not going to believe this. You're not going to believe this.
我当时正坐在厨房里，电话响了，是我妈打来的。她只是说，你绝对不会相信这个。你绝对不会相信这个。
It was the obit.
那是讣告。
She's like, and it's everywhere. And I'm like, wait a minute. I start to just google "Trapper Keeper inventor," and I started looking at all of the results. And it was like, all these-- all these publications, all these online people like bloggers. And I just was like-- and I didn't tell her. I go, yeah, OK, I see. Yeah, it's out there in the universe somewhere. And she's like, this is terrible. This is terrible. She was on fire.
她说，到处都是这个新闻。我说，等等。我开始用谷歌搜索“Trapper Keeper发明者”，我开始查看所有的结果。就像是，所有的出版物，所有那些像博主一样的在线人士。我当时就……我没告诉她。我说，是啊，好吧，我看到了。是的，它在世界某个地方流传着。她说，这太可怕了。这太可怕了。她当时火冒三丈。
Jackie told me Jon may be too polite to say it, but creating the Trapper Keeper has been a big part of his identity, his legacy. A few months before he talked to us, he was at his golf club.
Jackie告诉我，Jon可能太礼貌了所以说不出口，但创造Trapper Keeper一直是他身份认同和遗产的重要部分。在他和我们谈话的几个月前，他在高尔夫俱乐部。
I was talking to a couple, and I just happened to have a Mead jacket on. It said "Mead" on it. And this woman looked over and says, did you work for Mead. And I said, yes, I did. Yeah, 36 years. And she said, Mead, the Trapper Keeper. I said, well, that's interesting that you bring that up. [LAUGHS] I said, I was very involved in putting that little turkey together. And she said, oh, my god. Oh, she said that was the neatest school supply I-- oh. I said, I'm Trapper Jon. [LAUGHS]
我当时正和一对夫妇交谈，恰好穿着一件Mead夹克。上面写着“Mead”。这位女士看过来问道，你在Mead工作过吗？我说，是的，工作过。嗯，36年。她说，Mead，那个Trapper Keeper。我说，好吧，你提到这个很有趣。[笑声] 我说，我参与了组装那个小东西的过程。她说，天哪。哦，她说那是她用过的最整洁的学习用品。我说，我是“Trapper Jon”。[笑声]
Trapper Jon-- that's actually what some of his friends call him. Here's how Jon says the Trapper Keeper came to be. Back in the '70s, Jon was working as director of new product development at Mead. He was the person whose job was to build new stuff the company could sell. And he says Crutchfield, the guy in the obits who worked in marketing, came to him one day and asked him to make a binder that could hold these folders that had vertical pockets. Jon says there wasn't much more guidance than that.
“Trapper Jon”——这实际上是他的一些朋友这样称呼他。这是Jon描述Trapper Keeper诞生的经过。回到70年代，Jon在Mead担任新产品开发总监。他的工作就是制造公司可以销售的新产品。他说，讣告里提到的那个在市场部工作的Crutchfield，有一天来找他，要求他制作一个能容纳带有垂直口袋文件夹的活页夹。Jon说，除了这个，几乎没有更多的指导意见。
And so, over a few weeks, he put together the pieces that would become the trapper keeper. Jon says he designed the shape of the binder, the shape of the folders, the flap closure, the logo, and even the plastic clipboard in the back with the spot for the pencil. That was something he invented earlier with another guy.
于是，在几周的时间里，他组装出了后来成为Trapper Keeper的产品。Jon说，他设计了活页夹的形状、文件夹的形状、翻盖封口、标志，甚至还有背部带铅笔位的地方的塑料剪贴板。那是他之前和另一个人发明的。
It was a full three-dimensional prototype, designed, created with colors, named, the whole works. I can remember sitting at my desk with a tracing pad and tracing out of a typography book the logo. And it's still the same logo that's on the product today. It was the exact trapper keeper. Here it is.
这是一个完整的三维原型，经过设计，赋予颜色，命名，全套完成。我还记得坐在办公桌前，手里拿着描图纸，从排版书中描绘出标志。它仍然是今天产品上使用的同一个标志。这就是完全的Trapper Keeper。在这儿。
Jon says the whole idea that it would trap papers so they don't fall out, like the main sell of that commercial--
Jon说，整个“困住纸张以免掉出”的概念，就像那个广告的主要卖点一样——
This flap even has a Velcro closure to keep everything inside.
这个翻盖甚至还有魔术贴封口，可以把所有东西都锁在里面。
--Jon says that was him, too. He created the flap closure so nothing would fall out. He even came up with the name Trapper Keeper. Some of the obituaries actually give Jon credit for this. In The New York Times, they say over a martini-fueled lunch, Jon suggested the name to Bryant. It even quotes Bryant saying, "Bang! It made sense." That's the only mention Jon gets. He and his family, they're pretty sure Crutchfield deliberately cut him out of the story, grabbed all the credit for himself.
——Jon说这也是他的功劳。他设计了翻盖封口，这样东西就不会掉出来。他甚至想出了“Trapper Keeper”这个名字。有些讣告实际上把这一成就归功于Jon。在《纽约时报》的报道中，他们提到在一次马丁尼午餐会上，Jon向Bryant建议了这个名字。甚至引用了Bryant的话说：“砰！这很有道理。”这就是Jon得到的唯一提及。他和他的家人都非常确信，Crutchfield是有意将他从故事中抹去，把所有功劳据为己有。
Learning all of this, I felt for Jon. Maybe anybody would, but I really did. Like, "couldn't let it go" did. I feel a little silly saying this, but I identify with Jon. I'm also a behind the scenes kind of person. I hardly ever talk on the radio. I'm an editor here. I love helping make things happen in the background.
了解这一切后，我同情Jon。也许任何人都会，但我确实同情。就像那种“无法释怀”的感受一样。说出来可能有点傻，但我能与Jon产生共鸣。我也是那种幕后工作的人。我几乎从不在电台说话。我是这里的编辑。我喜欢在幕后协助促成事情。
So I saw myself in him. In fact, another producer started the story, Diane Wu, who you hear in some of the interviews. She lost interest in it, but I wouldn't let it die. It felt like if I could get his hard work noticed, the world, in some tiny, little way, would feel more fair.
所以我从他身上看到了自己。事实上，另一位制片人Diane Wu，你会在采访中听到她的声音，她曾开始负责这个故事，但后来失去了兴趣，但我坚持不让它夭折。我感觉，如果我能让他的辛勤工作得到认可，这个世界在某种细微程度上会感觉更公平一些。
So did some marketing guy do a marketing job on his own legacy-- like, convince the national press to tell the story he wanted told? Obviously, the person who would have answers was Crutchfield himself. But since that wasn't an option, I found his kids, Ken and Carol.
那么，那个营销人员是否对自己所留下的遗产进行了一次营销操作——比如，说服全国媒体去讲述他想要的那个版本的故事？显然，能给出答案的人是Crutchfield本人。但既然那已经不可能了，我找到了他的孩子Ken和Carol。
I'd seen Ken posting about how proud he was of his dad's accomplishments. I didn't relish the idea of calling these people whose dad had just died to say, there's this other guy who says he invented the trapper keeper, and your dad took all the credit for himself. But they were open to talking about it.
我看到Ken一直在发帖，炫耀他父亲的成就。我并不喜欢给这些父亲刚去世的人打电话，告诉他们：“有一个人说他发明了Trapper Keeper，而你父亲窃取了所有功劳。”但他们还是愿意谈论这件事。
Yeah, that sounds like my dad, something he would do.
是啊，听起来像我爸会做的事。
This is Carol, Crutchfield's daughter. I told her and her brother what Jon said, that her dad had been a big part of the Trapper Keeper's success, did great marketing for it, but that Jon was the one who actually built the thing.
这是Carol，Crutchfield的女儿。我告诉她和她哥哥Jon所说的话，即她父亲在Trapper Keeper的成功中扮演了重要角色，进行了出色的营销，但Jon才是实际制造产品的人。
Yeah, that makes sense that they were more than one person involved in creating the Trapper Keeper but, yeah, he took all the credit. I mean, it feels kind of yucky because-- I feel bad for them because I didn't know about him. But, yeah, it's uncomfortable.
是啊，如果说参与创造Trapper Keeper的人不止一个，那很合理，但他确实占有了所有功劳。我的意思是，这感觉有点恶心，因为——我为他们感到难过，因为我之前不知道他。但是，是的，这让人很不舒服。
Would it be out of character for your dad to play up his role in something?
你父亲夸大自己在某件事中的角色会显得反常吗？
He's always been a talker. And he is always somebody who thinks to talk about himself. That's what was one of his favorite subjects.
他一直是个话唠。而且他总是一个只想到谈论自己的人。那是他最喜欢的话题之一。
Here's what I learned about E. Bryant Crutchfield, or "Crutch," as his friends called him, from talking to his kids. Crutch was a memorable guy, could be a challenging guy. Fun-loving. Very proud of his kids. Big emphasis on providing for his family. Maybe some imposter syndrome. A big advice giver, a lover of drink. The martinis in the story made sense.
这是我从和他孩子们的交谈中了解到的E. Bryant Crutchfield，或者朋友们称呼的“Crutch”。Crutch是一个让人难忘的人，可能也是一个富有挑战性的人。热爱生活。对自己的孩子非常骄傲。非常强调供养家庭。也许有点冒名顶替综合征。一个喜欢给建议的人，爱喝酒。故事里提到的马丁尼确实说得通。
And Ken says that for most of his life, the Trapper Keeper wasn't a thing he talked about a lot. Ken wasn't even aware of his dad's relationship with the binder until about a decade ago, when a reporter for the website, Mental Floss, wrote a long story about the invention of the Trapper Keeper, and the piece was all about his dad. Ken's friends started sending him the article.
Ken说，在他大半辈子中，Trapper Keeper并不是他经常谈论的话题。Ken甚至直到大约十年前才知道他父亲与这个活页夹的关系，当时Mental Floss网站的一位记者写了一篇关于Trapper Keeper发明的长篇故事，整篇文章都是关于他父亲的。Ken的朋友们开始把这篇文章发给他。
I got a bit of a chuckle out of it, but I didn't really think much more of it than that. Because I think my dad has always been somebody to have certain narratives and things that he would talk about. So he managed to talk about Harvard in that article. If he was talking to a perfect stranger there's a couple of topics that would come up, and one of them was he would find a way to work into the conversation something about Harvard.
我稍微笑了笑，但并没有多想。因为我觉得我父亲一直是个有特定叙事方式的人，他会讲述某些事情。所以他在那篇文章中提到了哈佛。如果他和一个完全陌生的人交谈，会有几个话题冒出来，其中之一就是他会想办法在谈话中带入关于哈佛的内容。
What did he do at Harvard?
他在哈佛做了什么？
It was basically like a semester of an MBA program. So I think that was a proud thing for him, especially having grown up in Alabama and somebody that was the first to go to college, really, I think in his family.
基本上就像是一个MBA项目的一个学期。所以我认为这对他来说是一件值得骄傲的事，特别是因为他在阿拉巴马州长大，而且据我所知，他实际上是家里第一个上大学的人。
The Mental Floss story and the obits explain Crutch's role in creating the Trapper Keeper this way-- that Crutch was the one who spotted a need for something like the Trapper Keeper. The copy machine had made its way into schools. Kids had lots of papers. They needed a way to keep them in place. And Crutch had also learned that there was a different kind of folder that he thought would sell well. It had vertical pockets. He put those things together and sold it to the world, which, with this kind of product, is everything. As Ken puts it--
Mental Floss的故事和讣告是这样解释Crutch在创造Trapper Keeper中的角色的——Crutch是那个发现市场对像Trapper Keeper这类产品需求的人。复印机已经进入了学校。孩子们有很多纸张。他们需要一种方式把纸张固定好。Crutch还了解到有一种他认为会大卖的文件夹。它带有垂直口袋。他把这些东西结合在一起并卖给了全世界，对于这类产品来说，这才是关键。正如Ken所说——
The imagery, the pop culture, finding the trends, being able to reach the audience-- what, frankly, is kind of a complex sale. How many kids were able to buy their own product? Who had disposable income to buy it versus had to influence their parents to get the binder that they wanted?
形象，流行文化，捕捉趋势，能够触及受众——坦率地说，这是一个相当复杂的销售。有多少孩子能够自己购买产品？谁有可支配收入来购买，而不是不得不影响父母来买他们想要的活页夹？
Talking to Ken, reading the obits, I do think Crutch played a really significant role in the creation of the Trapper Keeper. I found this case study all about Crutch's approach to the project. I talked to a former boss. It really seems like the Trapper Keeper wouldn't have happened without him. I think he does deserve credit, just not all of it.
与Ken交谈，阅读讣告，我确实认为Crutch在Trapper Keeper的创造中发挥了非常重要的作用。我找到了一个关于Crutch处理该项目方法的案例研究。我与他的一位前任老板谈过。看起来，没有他，Trapper Keeper确实可能不会问世。我认为他确实应得一部分功劳，只是不能是全部。
That Mental Floss article seemed like it was the inspiration for all those obituaries when Crutch died. Both The New York Times and The Washington Post obits linked to it. And Carol says the Mental Floss article stirred things up for her dad back when he was still alive. He was in his 70s when that reporter called him up. Before that, Carol agreed with her brother. The Trapper Keeper wasn't a big topic for him.
那篇Mental Floss文章似乎是Crutch去世后所有讣告的灵感来源。《纽约时报》和《华盛顿邮报》的讣告都链接到了它。Carol说，Mental Floss的文章在生前给她父亲惹了不少事。那个记者给他打电话时，他已经70多岁了。在那之前，Carol同意她哥哥的说法。Trapper Keeper对他来说并不是一个重要的话题。
In the last, like, probably five years of his life, it was very much he would turn everything around to try to show that he had a legacy. He would stop people in the restaurant, say I invented the Trapper Keeper.
在他生命中最后的五年左右，他几乎会扭曲一切来证明他留下了遗产。他会拦住餐厅里的人说，是我发明了Trapper Keeper。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yeah. And I would find him over here talking to somebody, asking them what they're eating. And I'd have to go get him and say, leave these people alone. They're eating. Oh, but they want to hear about the Trapper Keeper.
是的。我会发现他在那边和某人聊天，问他们吃什么。我就不得不去把他拉走说，别打扰人家。他们正在吃饭。哦，但他们想听听关于Trapper Keeper的故事。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, and I think that came about after that whole Mental Floss interview. And that got him thinking, oh, I do have a legacy.
是的，我认为那是在整个Mental Floss采访之后发生的。这让他开始思考，哦，我确实留下了遗产。
Huh.
嗯。
And then he's just kind of went with that and focused on it. And look how good-looking I used to be. And I did this. So it was all ego. I'm sure my mother would love to hear that from me.
然后他就顺水推舟，专注于此。你看我过去长得多帅。我做了这个。所以这全都是自负。我敢肯定我母亲如果听到我这么说会很高兴。
Carol wanted to make it clear that she loved her dad. He was warm, very funny. Her friends loved him. She didn't think he was trying to be mean or steal anything. He was just the star of his own show.
Carol想表达清楚的是，她爱她的父亲。他很温暖，非常风趣。她的朋友们都很喜欢他。她不认为他是在试图刻薄或者窃取什么。他只是他自己人生剧场里的明星。
Like, if my dad was here right now and I asked him about Jon, he would say, oh, yeah, Jon did this, and Jon did that, and Jon did this. I don't think he would lie about it purposefully because my dad wasn't like that. I think his brain just kind of twisted facts to meet his own ego needs there towards the end.
比如，如果我父亲现在在这里，我问他关于Jon的事，他会说，哦，是的，Jon做了这个，Jon做了那个，Jon做了这个。我不认为他会故意撒谎，因为我父亲不是那种人。我认为他的大脑在晚年只是为了满足他自负的需求而扭曲了事实。
I was struck by how honest and thoughtful both kids were about their dad. And after talking to both of them, I got back in touch with John and Jackie, relayed what the Crutchfield kids had said, and they told me it made them feel better. Turns out Crutchfield's son wants to write a book about the trapper keeper and really wants to talk to Jon. I sent them each other's emails.
他们的孩子对他父亲评价如此诚实和深思熟虑，这让我深受触动。在与他们两人交谈后，我与Jon和Jackie取得了联系，转达了Crutchfield家孩子的话，他们告诉我这让他们感觉好受多了。原来Crutchfield的儿子想写一本关于Trapper Keeper的书，真的很想和Jon聊聊。我把他们的邮件地址发给了对方。
It's funny. As I worked on this story, I realized the reason I loved the Trapper Keeper actually has nothing to do with Jon or Crutch. It was the cover art-- those rainbows, and Lisa Frank images, and puppies, and palm trees. I'm pretty sure mine had an outer space scene with geometric shapes. I tried to find out who the artist was who deserves credit for that, but I haven't had any luck. If that happens to be your dad or mom, parent, please write me.
很有趣。在我做这个故事的时候，我意识到我喜欢Trapper Keeper的原因其实与Jon或Crutch无关。而是封面艺术——那些彩虹、Lisa Frank的图像、小狗和棕榈树。我很确定我的那一本上面是带有几何形状的外太空场景。我试着查出是哪位艺术家应该为此获得认可，但我没那么幸运。如果那恰好是你的父亲或母亲，请写信给我。
Phia Bennin hates being on the radio-- for now, anyway. We're working on her. She's an editor here at our show. Coming up, explaining the sex robots of the future to your great grandkids and other legacy issues we have yet to face, but will someday. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Phia Bennin讨厌在电台工作——至少目前是这样。我们正在努力改变她。她是这里节目的编辑。接下来，向你的曾孙辈解释未来的性机器人以及我们尚未面对但终有一天会面对的其他遗产问题。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共电台继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "How I Learned to Shave." Stories of our parents' legacies and what we learned from our dads, whether it's intended or not. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, "Raised by Wolf."
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天的节目，“我如何学会刮胡子”。关于父母遗产的故事，以及我们从父亲那里学到了什么，无论是否有意为之。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“狼养大的”。
So we now turn to this father and son who go hunting together, have all kinds of adventures, and then things get complicated. Both of them were raised by wolves because they are wolves. Here's Lilly Sullivan.
我们现在转向这对一起狩猎、经历各种冒险，然后情况变得复杂的父子。他们俩都是由狼抚养长大的，因为他们就是狼。这是Lilly Sullivan。
Rick McIntyre has spent more time watching wild wolves than anyone in the world. He's been doing it for over 40 years. His focus on them is singular and complete. He lives alone in a little cabin just outside of Yellowstone. And every day, seven days a week, he gets up before dawn, figures out where they are. He watches them, writes down what they do. It's now over 13,000 pages of field notes, single-spaced. And he's turned those notes into books.
Rick McIntyre花在观察野生狼身上的时间比世界上任何人都多。他已经做了40多年了。他对狼的专注是单一且完整的。他独自住在黄石公园外的一个小屋里。每天，一周七天，他都在黎明前起床，弄清楚它们在哪里。他观察它们，写下它们的一举一动。现在已经有超过13,000页的单倍行距现场笔记。他已经把这些笔记整理成了书。
Reading them, it's like you're out there with him, seeing what he sees. And you just watch the wolves. Lots of scientific papers have been based on his observations. Before Rick and others started doing this work, we really didn't know much about wolves-- well, except for one thing-- that we didn't want them around, even in Yellowstone.
读着这些书，就像你和他一起在野外，看着他所看到的。你只是静静地看着狼。许多科学论文都是基于他的观察。在Rick和其他人开始这项工作之前，我们对狼真的了解不多——好吧，除了一点——我们不想让它们靠近，即使是在黄石公园。
The early rangers back in the 1920s, like pretty much everyone else in America at that time, felt that wolves were no good and that they should all be killed off. And those early rangers did that job in a very thorough manner.
20世纪20年代的早期护林员，像当时美国的几乎每个人一样，认为狼是害虫，应该全部杀光。而那些早期的护林员非常彻底地执行了这项工作。
US Park Rangers killed off the last of the wolves in Yellowstone. Then, in the 1990s, we realized that was a big mistake. So we decided to reintroduce them by capturing three families of wild wolves from Canada and bringing them back to try to get them to settle in and repopulate the park.
美国公园护林员杀光了黄石公园最后的一批狼。然后，在90年代，我们意识到那是一个巨大的错误。于是我们决定通过捕捉加拿大三群野生狼并将它们带回来，试图让它们在这里定居并重新繁衍。
They put tracking collars on them so they could find them and watch them, which meant we could really learn what these animals were like in a way that hadn't been possible for most of history. That's what Rick's job was. And of all the things he observed, this is the story that got to him most, of two wolves, a father and a son.
他们给它们戴上追踪项圈，这样就能找到并观察它们，这意味着我们可以以历史上大部分时间里从未有过的方式真正了解这些动物。这就是Rick的工作。在他观察到的所有事情中，这个关于一对狼父子的故事最触动他。
We're going to start with the father, who was one of the first wolves to be reintroduced to Yellowstone. As Rick puts it in his book, "If Shakespeare were telling the story, he'd start it deep in a forest, deep in a wolf's den." Three pups come running out of the den, all robust and strong like their father. And then a fourth pup tumbles out after them, like an afterthought, a scrawny gray pup, the pup who seemed least likely to amount to anything.
我们将从父亲开始，它是第一批被重新引入黄石公园的狼之一。正如Rick在他的书中写道的：“如果莎士比亚在讲述这个故事，他会从森林深处、狼穴深处开始。”三只幼崽从洞穴里跑出来，像它们的父亲一样强壮有力。然后第四只幼崽像事后想起来一样滚了出来，那是一只瘦小的灰色幼崽，看起来最没出息的一只。
He was the runt of his litter. His three brothers were all bigger and stronger than him. And he looked different from everyone else in his family. He had a very dull, drab gray coat. His mother had a beautiful whitish coat. His father was jet black. And all of his brothers looked exactly like the father wolf. They also had black coats. So he really stood out, but stood out in a really bad way.
它是这窝里体型最小的一个。它的三个兄弟都比它大、比它强。而且它看起来和家里的其他人都不一样。它有一身暗淡、平庸的灰色皮毛。它的母亲有一身美丽的亮色皮毛。它的父亲是黑色的。所有的兄弟长得都和父亲狼一模一样。它们也有黑色的皮毛。所以它确实很突出，但却是以一种糟糕的方式突出。
His brothers constantly picked on him. He ate last. They would chase him around the pen. They would pin him and beat him up. And it was really a tough time for him.
它的兄弟们总是欺负它。它最后吃。它们会在围栏里追逐它。它们会按住它并打它。这对它来说确实是一段艰难的时光。
They named the pup Wolf 8 because the collars they gave the wolves, each one had a number. And his was number eight, so that became his name. These pups were all new to the park. Rick was kind of new to his job, too. This was the first time he'd ever gotten to watch wolves so closely. And Rick felt for 8 immediately, started calling him the little guy, worried about him. But then one day, he was watching 8 out playing with his brothers.
他们给这只幼崽取名“8号狼”，因为他们给狼戴的项圈上都有数字。它的项圈是8号，所以这成了它的名字。这些幼崽对公园来说都是新鲜事物。Rick对他的工作也有些陌生。这是他第一次有机会如此近距离地观察狼。Rick立刻就同情8号，开始叫它“小家伙”，担心它。但有一天，他看着8号和它的兄弟们玩耍。
And they were just fooling around, chasing each other. And suddenly, they stopped, and they steered into a pretty thick forest. And then they suddenly just ran at full speed into those trees.
它们当时只是在闹着玩，互相追逐。突然，它们停了下来，望向一片相当茂密的森林。然后它们突然全速跑进了那些树林。
Rick lost sight of them in the trees for a while. Then they came darting back out, the three bigger pups in the lead.
Rick在树林里有一会儿失去了它们的踪迹。然后它们又窜了出来，三只体型较大的幼崽在前面领头。
And then last in line, as usual because he was the slowest, was 8.
而最后面，像往常一样，因为它最慢，是8号。
One of the big pups was carrying a dead elk calf. At first, Rick was impressed that such young pups had taken down an elk.
其中一只大幼崽嘴里衔着一只死麋鹿幼崽。起初，Rick很惊讶，这么小的幼崽竟然捕杀了一只麋鹿。
But it turned out that they had not killed that elk. Because just behind 8, as he ran out of the trees, was a huge grizzly bear. And it was really the bear's elk calf. The bear was gaining on little 8. He was getting closer and closer. 8 was looking back over his shoulder. And it looked like at any moment, the bear would pounce on 8. 8 was maybe 60, 70 pounds at that time. The bear was maybe 400 pounds.
但事实证明它们并没有杀死那只麋鹿。因为就在8号跑出树林后，紧随其后的是一只巨大的灰熊。而且那确实是灰熊的麋鹿幼崽。熊正在追赶小8号。它越靠越近。8号正回头看向肩膀后方。看起来随时，熊都会扑向8号。8号那时可能也就60、70磅重。熊大约有400磅重。
But then little 8 just stopped, turned around, and confronted that huge grizzly. And somehow, it worked. The bear stopped. It looked at this little thing that was standing up to him like he didn't understand. And as the bear was confused, he had lost sight of 8's brother who had the elk calf. So now the bear literally didn't know what to do. So it basically just shrugged his shoulders, turned around, and walked off the other way. But that made me realize that there was really a lot more to this wolf than any of us had ever realized.
但随后小8号停了下来，转身面对那头巨大的灰熊。不知怎么的，这奏效了。熊停了下来。它看着这个站在面前挑战它的小东西，仿佛它不明白发生了什么。当熊感到困惑时，它已经失去了衔着麋鹿幼崽的8号兄弟的踪影。所以现在熊简直不知道该怎么办。它基本上耸了耸肩，转身向另一个方向走去。但这让我意识到，这只狼确实比我们任何人想象的要多得多。
His bigger, beautiful brothers didn't see this act of heroism. No one shared the elk with him. And they kept picking on him. As the months passed, 8 started spending more and more time alone to get away from them, just kind of wandering the forest, like a high schooler might do to get away from their family. And again, Rick felt for him, small like that, out there all by himself, with a family that didn't get him.
它那些更大、漂亮的兄弟们没有看到这个英雄行为。没有人跟它分享麋鹿。它们继续欺负它。随着几个月过去，8号开始花越来越多的时间独自待着以避开它们，就像高中生可能会为了避开家庭而做的那样，在森林里漫步。再次，Rick为它感到难过，体型那么小，独自在野外，带着一个不理解它的家庭。
Then one day, wolf 8 was out wandering alone as usual, when he ran into these wolf pups. Their mother was in a rough spot. She'd had a litter of eight pups, and she was all on her own. Because the same day she gave birth to her pups, her mate was illegally shot and killed.
然后有一天，8号像往常一样独自漫步，遇到了这些狼幼崽。它们的母亲处境艰难。她生了一窝八只幼崽，而且她独自一人。因为就在她生下幼崽的那天，她的配偶被非法射杀身亡。
And the thing is, it's really hard to raise wolf pups alone. In order to produce milk to feed them, she needed to hunt and eat. But that would mean leaving them alone. And newborn pups can't regulate their body temperature on their own. So starve or freeze-- she and her pups were screwed.
问题是，独自抚养狼崽非常困难。为了产奶喂养它们，她需要狩猎和进食。但这意味着要把它们独自留下。而刚出生的幼崽无法自己调节体温。所以要么饿死要么冻死——她和她的幼崽们完了。
The Wolf Project staff was so worried, they even captured the family for a bit so they could feed them. But then wolf 8 came along, the little guy, just a yearling, just out by himself. He saw these pups, and he started playing with them.
狼群项目的工作人员非常担心，他们甚至一度捕捉了这个家庭以便给它们喂食。但随后8号出现了，那个小家伙，只是个一岁大的幼崽，独自在外。它看到了这些幼崽，并开始和它们玩耍。
And the mother wolf was watching that from a distance, and she was desperate. She needed whatever help she could get. And he'd already made friends with all of her sons and daughters. So a moment later, she ran to him. They greeted each other. They played a bit.
母狼从远处看着，她绝望了。她需要任何能得到的帮助。而它已经和她所有的儿子女儿交朋友了。所以片刻后，她跑向它。它们互相问候。它们玩了一会儿。
8 liked this family. Over the next days, he started hunting for them, bringing them back little snacks. A little tangent I learned from the books-- a wolf often feeds pups by regurgitating the meat it's hunted. A wolf can carry up to 20 pounds of meat in its belly, which is easier than carrying that much in its jaws over a long distance. Once back at the den, the pups then trigger regurgitation by licking its face. That's why your dog licks your face. It's trying to get you to puke. Gross, right?
8号喜欢这个家庭。在接下来的几天里，它开始为它们狩猎，带回一些小零食。从书中我学到的一个小知识——狼通常通过反刍捕获的肉来喂养幼崽。狼可以在肚子里携带多达20磅的肉，这比在长距离下叼着那么重的肉更容易。回到巢穴后，幼崽会通过舔它的脸来触发反刍。这就是为什么你的狗舔你的脸。它是想让你吐出来。恶心，对吧？
So wolf 8's going out, hunting and bringing back these little snacks, as I said, all for these little pups. That was the first time they'd ever documented something like that-- a male wolf caring for another pack's pups, who he wasn't related to.
所以8号出去狩猎，带回这些小零食，就像我说的，都是为了这些小幼崽。那是他们第一次记录到这样的事情——雄狼照顾非亲生的其他狼群的幼崽。
And he was invited into the family, meaning now he went from being a picked on, bullied, undersized wolf, to being a big shot alpha male. Perhaps her first impression of seeing this undersized yearling wasn't that he was the best candidate, but he had shown up. He was there.
它被邀请进入了这个家庭，意味着现在它从一只被欺负、被霸凌、体型过小的狼，变成了一只大人物阿尔法雄狼。也许她第一次看到这只体型过小的幼崽时，并没有觉得它是最佳人选，但它出现了。它就在那儿。
He adopted those pups like they were his own. This is one of the things they were seeing while monitoring wolves, by the way. Wolves, like lots of creatures, they have really distinct personalities. And now they could see. Some wolves are aggressive. Some are aloof. And 8 seemed really-- I know how this sounds-- he seemed really nice.
它收养了那些幼崽，就像它们是它自己的一样。顺便说一句，这是他们在监测狼群时观察到的事情之一。狼，和许多生物一样，有非常独特的个性。现在他们能看出来了。有些狼好斗。有些狼冷漠。而8号看起来真的很——我知道这听起来如何——它看起来真的很好。
So that's the dad, which brings us to the second wolf in this story, the son, one of 8's adopted pups, known as 21. When 8 came along and started feeding the family, he and 21 really bonded, father and adopted son. Part of it was that 8 was young for a father, just a year older than the pups, so still puppy-like in lots of ways. 8 would do things like let all the pups attack him, roll on his back and pretend to lose to them. Or they might chase him around, and 8 would pretend to be scared and run away. Not all father wolves play with their pups like this. Some are standoffish or dominant.
这就是父亲，这把我们带到了这个故事里的第二只狼，儿子，8号收养的一只幼崽之一，被称为21号。当8号出现并开始喂养这个家庭时，它和21号建立了深厚的联系，父子关系（收养）。部分原因是8号作为父亲还很年轻，只比这些幼崽大一岁，所以在许多方面仍然像个幼崽。8号会做一些事情，比如让所有幼崽攻击它，翻身假装输给它们。或者它们可能会追逐它，而8号会假装害怕并逃跑。并不是所有的父亲狼都会这样和幼崽玩耍。有些比较疏离或专横。
But 21 seemed particularly connected to 8. As the years went on, the other pups in the litter wandered off, joined other packs. It was just what wolves do. 21, though, stayed first one year, and then another. There was one spring that their den was especially visible. And Rick's spotting scope had a clear view of them. So that whole season, Rick was able to watch them every day for hours on end as they chased and played.
但21号似乎特别与8号亲近。随着岁月的流逝，那窝里的其他幼崽离开了，加入了其他狼群。这就是狼的习性。不过21号留了下来，第一年，然后第二年。有一个春天，它们的洞穴特别明显。Rick的观测镜视野清晰。所以整个季节，Rick每天都能连续几个小时看着它们奔跑和玩耍。
And that's where I really began to understand the depth of the relationship between 8 and 21. It was the peak of my wolf watching career to be able to watch that.
也就是在那里，我真正开始理解8号和21号之间关系的深度。能看到这一点是我狼群观察生涯的巅峰。
They were a funny couple because 8 was so small, and 21, his son, grew huge, became significantly larger than his dad. Rick describes 21 as an almost cartoon version of a wolf. If you wanted to draw a wolf as a Marvel superhero, it'd look like 21. They'd go hunting together. 8 would decide when to go. And if 21 wasn't around, 8 would howl and wait. And then they'd head out together. When they found the prey, 21, so muscly and fast, would usually get there first and grab hold. Together, they'd take it down.
它们是一对有趣的搭档，因为8号很小，而它的儿子21号长得很大，明显比它父亲大得多。Rick形容21号几乎是一个动画版的狼。如果你想把狼画成漫威超级英雄，它看起来会像21号。它们会一起去狩猎。8号决定什么时候出发。如果21号不在附近，8号会嚎叫并等待。然后它们一起出发。当它们找到猎物时，强壮且快速的21号通常会先赶到并抓住猎物。它们一起把猎物拿下。
So they would go off and hunt. They would come back with food. They were just inseparable. They were buddies. They did everything together, with 8 being the older guy, the one in charge, 21 essentially being the apprentice.
它们会出去狩猎。它们会带着食物回来。它们简直不可分割。它们是好伙伴。它们一起做所有事情，8号是年长的那一个，负责的那一个，21号本质上是学徒。
Another season passed, and still, 21 stayed in the pack. He was nearly three at this point, which, honestly, is like too long for a grown-ass wolf to be living with his parents. It'd be like a 24-year-old with no friends, except for his mom and dad. Eventually, 21 did leave. And here's where things get complicated. He went to the pack right next door, what Rick and his team had been calling the Druid Peak pack, a pack that their family did not get along with. They'd battled in the past. There was still a lot of tension.
又一个季节过去了，21号仍然待在狼群里。此时它快三岁了，说实话，对于一只成年的狼来说，和父母住在一起太久了。就像一个24岁没有朋友，除了他妈和他爸的人。最终，21号确实离开了。而这里情况变得复杂了。它去了隔壁的狼群，Rick和他的团队一直称之为Druid Peak狼群，一个它们的家庭合不来的狼群。它们过去曾发生过战斗。仍然有很大的紧张气氛。
The Druid Peak pack was led by a female who was notoriously violent. And seriously, she was wild. She drove her own mother and sister out of the pack. Rick's pretty sure she killed entire litters of her sister's pups two years in a row. To this day, Rick calls her "the psychopath." And she was the leader.
Druid Peak狼群由一只以暴力闻名的雌狼领导。而且说真的，它很疯狂。它把自己母亲和姐妹赶出了狼群。Rick很肯定它连续两年杀死了它姐妹幼崽的整窝幼崽。直到今天，Rick还称它为“精神病患者”。而它就是首领。
The whole alpha male running the pack thing, by the way, one male beating all the others into submission, that's a myth. A pack is usually just a family of wolves, and the lead male is just the father. The one calling the shots is actually a female. She's in charge of strategy and decisions. And this female was terrifying. One year after 21 joined her pack, 21's sister wandered into the pack's territory. The psychopath just went off on her. Someone from the Wolf Project was in a plane, saw it all happen.
顺便说一句，所谓的阿尔法雄狼管理狼群这件事是个神话，即一只雄狼通过征服击败所有其他雄狼。狼群通常只是一个狼的家庭，而领头的雄狼只是父亲。真正指挥的是雌狼。它负责策略和决策。这只雌狼非常可怕。21号加入它的狼群一年后，21号的姐妹误入了该狼群的领地。那个“精神病患者”简直是对它下了狠手。狼群项目组的某个人在飞机上，目睹了这一切。
The researcher in the plane took photographs of what was happening. And I later looked at every one of those photographs. It was not a pretty sight. There was snow on the ground. And as the photos were taken, you could see more and more blood on the snow as she was biting at the helpless opponent.
飞机上的研究人员拍下了当时发生的事情的照片。我后来查看了那些照片中的每一张。那不是一个好看的场景。地上有雪。随着照片被拍下，你可以看到雪地上的血越来越多，因为它在啃咬那个无助的对手。
21 was there. But he was in her pack, and she was the leader. He didn't intervene. As the years went by, he got bigger, and their pack thrived. He became the lead male of the pack, and he had pups of his own. His true love seemed to be wolf 42, a real sweetheart, Rick says. They'd bed down together all the time.
21号当时就在那里。但它在她的狼群里，而她是首领。它没有介入。随着岁月流逝，它长得更大了，它们的狼群也壮大了。它成了狼群的领头雄狼，并且有了自己的幼崽。它的真爱似乎是42号狼，Rick说那真的是个甜心。它们总是睡在一起。
And his pack grew huge, too. Someone shot a documentary. A lot of the footage focused on 21, and 21 actually got famous for being this amazing, majestic wolf. People would travel to Yellowstone to see him. No one really came to see his dad.
它的狼群也变得非常庞大。有人拍了一部纪录片。很多镜头都聚焦在21号身上，21号因为成为这只令人惊叹、雄伟的狼而变得出名。人们会前往黄石公园看它。没多少人是来看它父亲的。
One winter, the tension started to escalate between 21's pack, the Druid Peak pack, and his father wolf 8's pack. Rick would be at home and hear the packs howling at each other from across the valley. He could tell from their radio collars that they were encroaching on each other's territory. Neither side seemed to be backing down.
有一个冬天，21号的狼群（Druid Peak狼群）和它父亲8号的狼群之间的紧张局势开始升级。Rick在家时会听到狼群在山谷对面互相嚎叫。他能从它们的无线电项圈中看出它们正在侵入对方的领地。双方似乎都没有退缩的意思。
The main way wolves in the park die is in fights with other wolves. Rick had seen wolf fights. They could be brutal. And if a clash came, 21 and his father, 8, would be pitted against each other. 21's job was to protect his pack, and 8's job was to protect his.
公园里狼死亡的主要方式是与其他狼战斗。Rick见过狼群战斗。它们可能很残酷。如果发生冲突，21号和它父亲8号将会处于对立面。21号的工作是保护它的狼群，而8号的工作是保护它的。
I was very worried about 8. He was now very old. He had a lot of health problems. He was losing his strength and his speed. 21 was middle-aged at that point. He was at the peak of his strength and fighting ability. He had never lost a fight in his life. He was the undefeated heavyweight champion of Yellowstone.
我非常担心8号。它现在非常老了。它有很多健康问题。它正在失去力量和速度。21号在那时处于中年。它处于力量和战斗能力的巅峰。它一生中从未输过战斗。它是黄石公园未尝败绩的重量级冠军。
Then there was the lead female, the vicious one. 8 would be up against her, too.
还有那个邪恶的领头雌狼。8号也要面对它。
I was in Lamar Valley. I was getting signals from both the Druid Peak pack to the east. I get the signal from 8's family to the west. Both of those packs were traveling toward each other. It looked like they were both traveling on the same ridge, Specimen Ridge, on the south side of Lamar Valley. They were moving toward each other, meaning that there was going to be a fight.
我当时在拉马尔山谷。我接收到来自东部Druid Peak狼群的信号。我接收到来自西部8号家庭的信号。这两个狼群都在向对方前进。看起来它们都在同一座山脊上，即拉马尔山谷南侧的标本岭（Specimen Ridge）。它们正在向对方靠近，这意味着战斗即将发生。
One side howled. The other side howled. It was January. There was snow out. Rick pulled over in his truck, got his spotting scope on the wolves. 8's pack was up on the ridge. 21's pack was running uphill through forests and meadows. 21 was out in front of his pack. 8 was in front of his. Both packs were charging at each other.
一方嚎叫。另一方嚎叫。那是1月。雪地里。Rick把卡车停在路边，用观测镜盯着狼群。8号的狼群在山脊上。21号的狼群穿过森林和草地向山上跑去。21号在它狼群的前面。8号在它的前面。两个狼群正冲向对方。
So here I was watching the two wolves that I admired the most in the world, father and adopted son running at each other. They started to come together. They were charging each other. 8, he wasn't running as fast, but he was still out in front of his family. And nothing was going to stop him.
所以我就在这里，看着世界上我最钦佩的两只狼，父子俩正冲向对方。它们开始汇合。它们在向对方冲锋。8号，它跑得没那么快，但它仍然在它家庭的最前面。没有什么能阻止它。
I mean, even now, thinking about it, I'm in great distress because I remember how I felt then. I did not want to see 8 killed. I did not want to see him torn apart. Of all the deaths that could befall 8, in my mind, this would be the very worst. This would be such a horrible ending to their story.
我是说，即使现在想起来，我依然感到非常痛苦，因为我记得那时我的感受。我不想看到8号被杀。我不想看到它被撕成碎片。在所有可能降临到8号身上的死亡中，在我看来，这将是最糟糕的。这对它们的故事来说将是一个如此可怕的结局。
Rick starts ticking through possibilities, trying to figure out if there was some way out. 21 could just pin 8 down and let him go. But no, that wouldn't work. The psychopath was right behind 21. She'd surely jump in and kill 8. No question.
Rick开始权衡各种可能性，试图找出是否有出路。21号可以只是把8号按住然后放它走。但不行，那样没用。那个“精神病患者”就在21号后面。它肯定会冲上去杀死8号。毫无疑问。
And I was just helpless that there was nothing that I could do as a researcher other than just watch and document what was about to happen in front of me. They got to within 40 yards, 30 yards, 20 yards, 10 yards. And I knew, just in a moment, it was all going to be over.
作为一名研究人员，我束手无策，除了看着并记录下即将发生在我面前的一切，我什么也做不了。它们进入了40码，30码，20码，10码距离内。我知道，就在那一刻，一切都将结束。
So there I am, standing there, looking through my spotting scope. The moment arrives. They're just a couple of feet apart from each other. Well, in that moment, 21 did something-- ran right past 8 without stopping. Just in the very slightest way, 21 angles away and just shoots past 8.
所以我站在那里，透过观测镜看着。那一刻来了。它们彼此只有几英尺的距离。嗯，就在那一刻，21号做了件事——绕过8号径直跑了过去，没有停下。就在最轻微的瞬间，21号斜着跑开并从8号身边飞掠过去。
It was the strangest thing, two sides heading into battle and then running right past each other. 21's pack kept following 21 because he's leading the charge. So when he sprinted past, they just kept following him.
这是最奇怪的事情，双方进入战斗，然后直接冲过了对方。21号的狼群继续跟着21号，因为它是冲锋的领导者。所以当它冲过去时，它们也继续跟着它。
All the other Druid wolves ran past 8 and all the other wolves. And 8 didn't have the ability to turn around. He just kept on going as well. Wolves from both packs, they were just running back and forth. They were howling at each other. It was a confusing situation. No wolves were harmed. No wolves were fighting. And that was the end of the fight that never was.
Druid狼群的其他狼都跑过了8号和其他狼。而8号也没有能力回头。它也继续向前。两个狼群的狼，它们只是来回跑动。它们互相嚎叫。情况很混乱。没有狼受伤。没有狼在战斗。这就是那场未发生的战斗的结局。
This happened 23 years ago. But Rick still thinks about it all the time, wondering what happened that day. Rick's convinced that what 21 did that day was intentional. He thinks that 21 changed the battle into a game of chase, knowing that the other wolves would keep following him, and also, that he could outrun them all.
这发生在23年前。但Rick仍然经常想这件事，想那天发生了什么。Rick深信，21号那天所做的是故意的。他认为21号把战斗变成了一个追逐游戏，知道其他狼会继续跟着它，而且，它能跑过它们所有人。
21 had just come up with this genius solution to save the wolf that had raised him. It was probably the most emotional moment of my life.
21号刚刚提出了这个天才的解决方案来拯救养育它的狼。这可能是我一生中最感动的时刻。
It was the most emotional moment of your life?
这是你一生中最感动的时刻？
Yes. By that time, I had known 21 and 8 for so many years. And I respected and admired them for so much. I was rooting for 8 to somehow survive. But the reality was, I didn't see any way that that could be the end of the story. And somehow, 21 figured it out. He saved the day.
是的。到那时，我已经认识21号和8号很多年了。我对它们充满敬意和钦佩。我当时正祈祷8号能以某种方式活下来。但现实是，我没看出故事还能以其他方式结束。而不知何故，21号想到了办法。它拯救了一切。
Rick had been watching 8 and 21 day after day for years, their whole lives. And 8 was such a nice wolf. I know how that sounds, but I really can't think of a better word for it. You'd think that in a world as brutal as theirs, niceness could get you killed. But in the end, it was the thing that saved him. After all, 21 learned how to be a wolf from 8. It's like a dad who just poured out all this love, and the son inherited it.
Rick多年来日复一日地观察8号和21号，它们的整个生命。而8号是一只如此好的狼。我知道这听起来如何，但我真的想不出更好的词。你会认为在一个像它们那样残酷的世界里，好心可能会让你丧命。但最终，正是这种特质救了它。毕竟，21号是跟8号学会如何做一只狼的。就像一位倾注了所有爱的父亲，而儿子继承了它。
Lilly Sullivan is a producer on our show. Rick McIntyre told the story of 8 and 21 in his book, The Rise of Wolf 8. Rick says wolf 8 died a few months after the fight that never was. From what it looked like, he died taking care of his pack. An elk kicked him in the head while he was out hunting for them.
Lilly Sullivan是我们节目的制片人。Rick McIntyre在他的书《8号狼的崛起》（The Rise of Wolf 8）中讲述了8号和21号的故事。Rick说，8号狼在那场未发生的战斗几个月后去世了。看起来，它是为了照顾狼群而死的。当它外出为狼群捕猎时，一只麋鹿踢中了它的头部。
Act Three, "Storycorp, The Post-Apocalypse Edition." We close out our show today with Simon Rich, who has this story about a dad who is also a grandfather and a great grandfather, who has some very strong ideas about what he wants family members who come after him to know about him and his life.
第三幕，“Storycorp，后启示录版”。今天我们要以Simon Rich的故事结束我们的节目，讲述一位同时是祖父和曾祖父的父亲，他对那些继承他生命的人希望知道关于他及他生活的某些想法非常强烈。
I interviewed my great-grandfather Simon because he is the oldest person in my family who is still alive. He was born in a country called America on Earth. He said he used to be a writer. I asked him if he wrote Spider-Man, and he said no. He wrote other things that have all been lost.
我采访了我的曾祖父Simon，因为他是我们家目前仍活着的最年长的人。他出生在一个叫美国的国家，在地球上。他说他曾经是一名作家。我问他是不是他写了《蜘蛛侠》，他说没有。他写了其他所有的东西，但那些都丢失了。
My great-grandfather was one of the only men to escape from Earth. The rest of the people who got seats on the escape pod were women and children. My great-grandfather says they let him on because they needed one man to row the spaceship. I'm not sure what he means because there are no oars on a spaceship, but that is what he said.
我的曾祖父是仅有的几名从地球逃离的男人之一。剩下坐在逃生舱上的是妇女和儿童。我的曾祖父说，他们让他上船是因为他们需要一个男人来划飞船。我不确定他是什么意思，因为宇宙飞船上没有桨，但这就是他说的。
My great-grandfather told me how scary it was when Earth became too hot to live on. The skies burned with fire day and night, and you couldn't walk across the street without collapsing. I asked him if he had any kind of warning about climate change, and he said yes. There had been articles, movies, and books about how it was going to happen. I asked him if he tried to stop it from happening, and he said, yes, of course. I asked him how, and he said that he had done something called recycling, which is where you throw your garbage into different colored boxes.
我的曾祖父告诉我，当地球变得太热而无法居住时是多么可怕。天空日夜燃烧着火焰，你不塌陷就无法走过街道。我问他是否收到过关于气候变化的预警，他说有。有很多关于它将会发生的文章、电影和书籍。我问他是否试图阻止它发生，他说，当然。我问他怎么做的，他说他做了一件叫“回收”的事，就是把垃圾扔进不同颜色的箱子里。
I asked my mom what he was talking about. And she explained that when people become as old as my great-grandfather, their brains start to break down. And it's almost like they turn back into babies. Since my great-grandfather is going to die soon, and he is one of the only survivors of Earth, I decided to ask him what his favorite memory of the planet was. I thought he might tell me about the end of World War IV or going to see Spider-Man, but instead, he told me about the first date he went on with his wife, my great-grandmother Kathleen.
我问妈妈他在说什么。她解释说，当人们变得像我曾祖父那么老时，他们的大脑开始退化。就像他们变成了婴儿一样。既然我的曾祖父快要死了，而且他是地球仅存的幸存者之一，我决定问他关于这个星球最喜欢的记忆是什么。我想他可能会告诉我关于第四次世界大战的结束，或者是去看《蜘蛛侠》，但相反，他告诉了我他和妻子，也就是我的曾祖母Kathleen的第一次约会。
They met in college, which is a place people used to go to after high school to drink alcohol. My great-grandfather said that when he was in college, online dating hadn't been invented yet. Instead of matching with someone through a dating app and sending a series of nude photos to each other before eventually meeting up for sex, you would meet them in person before doing anything else. This meant that when my great-grandparents went out for the first time, they had no idea what each other looked like naked.
他们在大学相遇，那是人们在高中毕业后去喝酒的地方。我曾祖父说，当他在大学时，还没有发明在线约会。不是通过约会软件匹配某人并互发一系列裸照，然后在最终见面之前。你会先亲自见面，然后再做任何事情。这意味着当我的曾祖父母第一次出去时，他们根本不知道对方没穿衣服时是什么样子。
At this point, my mother, who is recording our interview, told my great-grandfather that he was being inappropriate because this was a project for school. And he apologized, but said that the naked stuff was crucial to the story and that he was going to keep bringing it up whenever it was relevant. My great-grandfather explained that not only had they not seen each other naked, he wasn't sure if my great grandmother wanted that to happen.
此时，正在记录我们采访的母亲告诉我的曾祖父，他不恰当，因为这是一个学校项目。他道歉了，但说没穿衣服的事情对故事至关重要，他会在任何相关的时候继续提及。我的曾祖父解释说，他们不仅没见过对方没穿衣服的样子，他不确定我的曾祖母是否希望发生那种事。
Sometimes, in those days, when someone agreed to go out on a date with you, they were still undecided about the naked thing and wanted to learn more personal information about you before making up their mind. Since this was before social media, the only way to get this personal information was by asking people questions to their face, like, as if their actual living, breathing face was their social media profile.
在那些日子里，有时当某人同意和你约会时，他们对那个没穿衣服的事还没拿定主意，想在下定决心前更多地了解你的个人信息。由于这是在社交媒体出现之前，获取这些个人信息的唯一方式就是当面问人问题，就好像他们活生生、呼吸的面孔就是他们的社交媒体个人资料一样。
Sometimes this would get embarrassing. Like, you might say, what do your parents do, and they would say, my parents are dead. And then you would have to say something like, I'm sorry I didn't know that because I have no information about you. We're strangers.
有时这会变得尴尬。比如，你可能会问，你父母做什么的，他们会说，我父母去世了。然后你就不得不说些像，对不起，我不知道，因为我对你一无所知。我们是陌生人。
The point, my great-grandfather said, is that he had no idea what my great-grandmother thought about him. He had no idea what she thought about anything. He had zero information about her, other than what she looked like wearing clothes and also how it sounded when she laughed, which she had done a couple of times on their long, slow walk through campus with the cool fall breeze whipping through the scattered leaves.
重点是，我曾祖父说，他根本不知道我曾祖母对他怎么想。他不知道她对任何事怎么想。他对她一无所知，除了她穿着衣服的样子，以及她笑起来的声音，那笑声她在校园里漫步时曾出现过几次，带着凉爽的秋风吹过散落的树叶。
My great-grandfather said that all dates began with the same custom. The two people on the date would take turns verbally listing all the TV shows they liked. If they both liked the same show, they'd exchange memes from it. But here's the thing-- GIFs did not exist yet. So instead of texting the other person a funny moment from the show, you would say out loud, do you remember the part when? And then you would perform the meme yourself, using your face and body to imitate what an actor had said and done.
我曾祖父说所有的约会都始于同一个习惯。约会的两个人轮流口头列出他们喜欢的电视剧。如果他们都喜欢同一个节目，他们会交换里面的梗。但问题是——那时候还没有GIF图。所以不是发给对方节目里的搞笑瞬间，而是你会大声说，你记得那个片段吗？然后你自己模仿那个梗，用你的脸和身体模仿演员说过和做过的事。
Exchanging memes in person was much scarier than doing it by text. Because when you text someone a meme and they don't respond, you can tell yourself that maybe they liked it, but just didn't have time to text you back. But when you performed a meme with your body and the other person didn't like it, you would be able to tell. Because instead of laughing, they would just kind of sadly look away and say, yeah, I remember that part. And you would have to just keep on walking to the restaurant.
当面交换梗比用短信更可怕。因为当你给某人发梗而他们没回应时，你可以告诉自己也许他们喜欢，只是没时间回短信。但当你用身体表演梗而对方不喜欢时，你能看得出来。因为他们不会笑，只是悲伤地移开目光说，是啊，我记得那部分。而你就不得不继续走到餐厅。
Luckily, though, my great-grandfather's meme performances went over well, or at least well enough to keep the conversation going. And while he still had no idea whether they would ever see each other naked, he knew it was at least technically still possible. My great-grandfather had invited my great-grandmother to a Spanish restaurant because it was the only restaurant he knew that served wine to people under 21.
幸运的是，我曾祖父的梗表演效果不错，或者至少好到能让对话继续下去。虽然他还是不知道他们是否会见过对方没穿衣服的样子，但他知道这在技术上至少仍然是有可能的。我曾祖父邀请我曾祖母去一家西班牙餐厅，因为那是他知道的唯一一家给21岁以下的人提供葡萄酒的餐厅。
But when they arrived, it was too crowded to get a table. They needed to find some other place to eat, but neither of them had internet access. So their only option was to physically search for food by walking around and looking in random directions, like truly the same process used by animals.
但当他们到达时，那里太拥挤了，没有座位。他们需要找别的地方吃饭，但他们都没有互联网接入。所以唯一的选择就是通过四处走动、向随机方向寻找来寻找食物，就像动物使用的过程一样。
Things grew tense. The sun had set, and my great-grandfather was fearful that they would not be able to find alcohol. But after a few stressful minutes, they followed the scent of fried food around a corner and found a Chinese place that served beer. And they were so proud of themselves that they spontaneously high fived, and that was the first time that they touched.
情况变得紧张起来。太阳下山了，我曾祖父担心他们找不到酒精。但在几分钟压力重重后，他们顺着炸食的香味转过拐角，找到了一家提供啤酒的中餐厅。他们为自己感到骄傲，以至于自发地击掌，那是他们第一次身体接触。
My great-grandfather told me they stayed at the restaurant so long that, by the end, they were the only customers left. Because they were strangers, they asked each other very basic questions, like who are you? Where did you come from? What kind of a person are you?
我曾祖父告诉我，他们在餐厅待了很久，以至于到最后，他们是剩下的唯一顾客。因为他们是陌生人，他们问了彼此非常基本的问题，比如你是谁？你从哪儿来？你是怎样的人？
They ended up having a lot of things in common, which was exciting because that didn't usually happen on a first date. Often, the other person would dislike things you liked or love things that you hated. Or things would seem to be going pretty well, and the person would seem really nice, but then out of the blue, they would say, what is your relationship with Jesus Christ.
他们最后发现有很多共同点，这很令人兴奋，因为那在第一次约会中并不常见。通常，对方会不喜欢你喜欢的东西，或者喜欢你厌恶的东西。或者事情看起来进行得不错，那个人看起来真的很好，但突然间，他们会问，你和耶稣基督的关系如何。
My great-grandfather said the main thing he talked to my great grandmother about was how nervous they both were about the future. I asked if he meant climate change. And he admitted that the imminent climate holocaust hadn't come up much. And instead, they'd mostly talked about their careers.
我曾祖父说，他和曾祖母谈论的主要内容是他们对未来有多么紧张。我问他是指气候变化吗。他承认临近的气候大屠杀并没有被多谈。相反，他们谈论的主要是他们的职业。
It turned out they both had the same dream-- to write stories down onto pieces of paper. In fact, they were both already trying to do that. Every day, they would each type out stories on computers and then print them with ink onto pieces of white paper. Their goal was to get better at making these paper stories in the hopes that someday they might be able to persuade someone to reprint their paper stories onto multiple pieces of paper, and then sell those pieces of paper for pieces of money, which were also made of paper.
原来他们俩有同一个梦想——把故事写在纸上。事实上，他们两人已经在尝试那样做了。每天，他们各自在电脑上打出故事，然后用墨水打印在白纸上。他们的目标是提高制作这些纸上故事的水平，希望有一天能说服某人将他们的纸上故事重印在多张纸上，然后卖掉这些纸来换取钱币，钱币也是纸做的。
At this point, my mother whispered to me that it was time for my great-grandfather to take a nap, and she gave him some medicine which made him sleep for about four hours. When he woke up, though, he was still insisting all this paper stuff was real, and that it was their actual shared ambition to write stories down on paper and then sell the paper for more paper.
此时，我母亲低声对我说是时候让曾祖父打个盹了，她给了他一些药，让他睡了大约四个小时。然而，当他醒来时，他仍然坚持所有这些纸的事情是真的，这是他们真正的共同抱负，即把故事写在纸上，然后卖纸换更多的纸。
And my mother smiled, and rubbed his hand, and said she believed him. But while she was doing that, she buzzed for the doctor. And he brought in this huge syringe that was almost like a gun because it was made out of metal, and it had this trigger on the bottom.
我母亲微笑着，抚摸他的手，说她相信他。但在她做那件事的时候，她按了医生的铃。医生带进来这支巨大的注射器，几乎像一把枪，因为它是由金属制成的，底部有一个扳机。
And the doctor explained that he was going to shoot this thing into my great-grandfather's brain to make him less confused. And my great-grandfather laughed weirdly and said that he had been joking about all that paper stuff, and that really what he and his wife had talked about on their first date was climate change. Because that's what any sane person from that era would have prioritized-- being a climate warrior.
医生解释说他要把这东西射进我曾祖父的大脑，让他不再困惑。我曾祖父奇怪地笑了笑，说他之前是在开玩笑，说的所有纸的事情都不是真的，他和妻子在第一次约会上谈论的是气候变化。因为那是那个时代任何理智的人都会优先考虑的事——成为气候斗士。
And the doctor looked into my great-grandfather's eyes with his finger on the trigger and said, are you sure? And my great-grandfather swallowed and said, yep. And so the doctor left. But on his way out, he told my mom that he would stay nearby in case my great-grandfather got confused again, in which case he would come back and give him that gunshot right in the middle of his brain.
医生看着我曾祖父的眼睛，手指扣在扳机上说，你确定吗？我曾祖父吞了口唾沫说，是的。于是医生离开了。但在他出门时，他告诉妈妈他会待在附近，以防曾祖父再次困惑，那样他会回来给他那致命的一枪，正好在大脑中间。
My great-grandfather was quiet for a while, almost like he was afraid to keep going with his story. But I pressed him for more information. And he said the main thing he wanted me to know before was not what he and my great-grandmother talked about, it was how they talked. Because even though they were basically still strangers who had never even seen each other naked, they somehow believed in one another from the start.
曾祖父沉默了一会儿，好像害怕继续讲他的故事。但我迫使他提供更多信息。他说，他想让我知道的最主要的事不是他和曾祖母谈论的内容，而是他们谈论的方式。因为即使他们基本还是从未见过对方没穿衣服的陌生人，他们却不知何故从一开始就相信对方。
My great-grandfather told me that all dates ended with the same custom. After the two people finished all the alcohol they'd been served, one person would ask the other to come over to their dorm room to watch Arrested Development. Arrested Development was a non Spider-Man show that you played by putting small round disks into a machine. The reason it existed was to create a way for people on dates to gauge each other's interests in becoming naked without having to directly ask them.
我曾祖父告诉我，所有的约会都以同一个习惯结束。在两个人喝完他们被提供的所有酒后，一个人会邀请另一个人去他们的宿舍看《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）。《发展受阻》是一个非《蜘蛛侠》的节目，通过把小圆盘放入机器里播放。它之所以存在是为了创造一种方式让约会的人在不用直接开口的情况下评估对方变得没穿衣服的兴趣。
The way this worked was a little complicated, but my great-grandfather was able to explain all the steps. First, you ask the other person if they had seen Arrested Development, and they would respond, "Some, but not all of it." This would be your prompt to ask them if they wanted to come to your dorm room to watch the episodes they'd missed. If they didn't want to see you naked, they would say that they had to finish a paper, which was an expression that meant that they were not attracted to you. If they did agree to watch Arrested Development, it meant that they probably did want to see you naked.
这种运作方式有点复杂，但我曾祖父能够解释所有步骤。首先，你问对方是否看过《发展受阻》，他们会回答：“看过一些，但没看完。”这将是提示你问他们是否想去你的宿舍看他们错过的剧集。如果他们不想见你没穿衣服的样子，他们会说他们得完成一篇论文，那是一种意味着他们对你没感觉的表达。如果他们同意看《发展受阻》，这意味着他们可能确实想见你没穿衣服的样子。
But here's where it gets complicated. Sometimes it did not mean that. Sometimes it just meant that they wanted to watch Arrested Development. That's why there was a third part of the custom. After walking back to your dorm room and putting one of the disks into the disk playing machine, you would sit side by side on a small couch. Your eyes would be facing the screen, but your attention would be focused entirely on each other.
但这就是复杂之处。有时那并不意味着那样。有时那只是意味着他们真的想看《发展受阻》。这就是为什么有习惯的第三部分。走回宿舍把光盘放进光盘播放机器后，你会并排坐在小沙发上。你的眼睛会对着屏幕，但你的注意力会完全集中在对方身上。
As Arrested Development played, you would physically move closer to the other person, inch by inch, without making any sudden movements. The idea was that if you both moved incrementally towards each other, eventually, your hands would touch. If the other person pulled their hand away or laughed and said, sorry, that meant that they had really truly come to watch Arrested Development.
随着《发展受阻》播放，你会物理上向对方移动，一英寸一英寸地移动，不做任何突然的动作。主意是如果你们都向对方移动，最终你们的手会碰到。如果对方把手抽走或笑说抱歉，那意味着他们真的、真的是来看《发展受阻》的。
But if they did not pull their hand away from yours, that meant it was time to start kissing, which is what my great-grandparents did, even though they had never exchanged even the most rudimentary of nudes. And at this point, my mother told my great grandfather to stop telling the story. And he had to admit that the next part was genuinely inappropriate.
但如果他们没有把手从你的手中抽走，那就意味着是时候开始接吻了，这就是我的曾祖父母所做的，尽管他们甚至从未交换过最基本的裸照。此时，我母亲告诉曾祖父别再讲故事了。他不得不承认下一部分确实不合适。
My great-grandfather said that their marriage wasn't perfect. Sometimes they argued. And in the 2050s, they both had full-fledged affairs with sex robots. But they ultimately forgave each other because nobody's perfect. And also, by the 2050s, sex robots had become extremely advanced, as well as incredibly persuasive. If you refused to have sex with them, they would start making really high level philosophical arguments about why it wasn't wrong, using logic that was essentially bulletproof, while their boobs and dicks lit up and spun and stuff.
我曾祖父说他们的婚姻并不完美。有时他们会争吵。在2050年代，他们俩都和性机器人发生过全面的外遇。但他们最终原谅了彼此，因为没有人是完美的。而且，到2050年代，性机器人也变得极其先进，以及令人难以置信的具有说服力。如果你拒绝和它们发生关系，它们会开始进行非常高水平的哲学论证，解释为什么那没有错，使用本质上无懈可击的逻辑，同时它们的胸部和生殖器会发光并旋转之类。
And eventually, it got to the point where the UN had to regulate the sex robot industry because they needed people to leave their apartments again so we could go back to being a society. The point is, my great-grandparents rekindled their romance in the 2060s. And they even ended up renewing their vows while riding on the escape pod to New Earth, surrounded by their daughters and their grandchildren.
最终，联合国不得不监管性机器人产业，因为他们需要人们再次离开公寓，这样我们才能恢复成为一个社会。重点是，我的曾祖父母在2060年代重燃了他们的爱。他们甚至在前往新地球的逃生舱上重申了誓言，周围是他们的女儿和孙子们。
And my great-grandfather asked my mom if she could remember the ceremony. And she said she was only four at the time, but she did vaguely recall how weird it was to see him on the spaceship when it was supposed to be just for women and children. And my great-grandfather said that they needed to bring one man to help the women lift their bags into the overhead compartments. And I reminded him that earlier he'd said he'd been on the ship to row an oar.
我曾祖父问妈妈是否记得那场仪式。她说她当时只有四岁，但她模糊地记得看到他在宇宙飞船上是多么奇怪，因为那里本应该是妇女和儿童的空间。我曾祖父说，他们需要带一个男人来帮助妇女把包抬到头顶的行李舱。我提醒他，他之前说过他在船上是为了划桨。
And there was a long pause. And then he said that he was tired and had to go to sleep. And he closed his eyes, but it didn't really look like he was sleeping. Because every few seconds, he would open his eyes to check if we were still there. And when he saw we were, he would quickly close his eyes again.
有很长的一阵沉默。然后他说他累了，必须去睡觉。他闭上了眼睛，但看起来并不像是在睡觉。因为每隔几秒，他就会睁开眼睛检查我们是否还在那儿。当他看到我们还在时，他会迅速再次闭上眼睛。
And it was around this time that my great-grandmother rolled up in her wheelchair. And my great-grandfather stopped pretending to be asleep, and he sat up and smiled. And she smiled back. And then he lowered his voice and said, do you want to watch Arrested Development? And my mom reminded my great-grandfather that Arrested Development has been lost, along with everything else on Earth, because of his generation's crimes against humanity.
大约在这个时候，我的曾祖母坐着轮椅过来了。我曾祖父停止了假装睡觉，他坐起来微笑了。她也回以微笑。然后他压低声音说，你想看《发展受阻》吗？我妈妈提醒曾祖父，《发展受阻》和地球上的一切一样，因为他那一代人对人类犯下的罪行而丢失了。
But my great-grandfather ignored her and motioned for his wife to wheel next to him. And he flipped through random channels while their hands inched slowly towards each other. And that's when I finally figured out what the Earth was really like. It was kind of like Arrested Development. It was something people talked about, and praised, and maybe even tried to save.
但我曾祖父没理她，示意他的妻子轮椅推到他旁边。他拨弄着随机频道，同时他们的手慢慢向对方移动。就在那时，我终于弄清楚了地球曾经的样子。那有点像《发展受阻》。那是人们谈论、赞美，甚至试图拯救的东西。
But the whole time, what everybody secretly actually cared about was the person sitting next to them. That's where all mankind's effort went, the sweat and the toil of billions not to saving the world, but to the frantic, desperate quest for love. And that's why the Earth is gone, because it was nothing more than a conversation starter. It wasn't what we really truly cared about. We never even really lived there. We lived in the presence of each other.
但整个时间里，每个人私下里真正在乎的是坐在身边的那个人。这就是人类所有努力的去处，数十亿人的汗水和辛劳不是为了拯救世界，而是为了疯狂、绝望地追求爱。这就是为什么地球没了，因为它不过是一个谈话的开场白。它不是我们真正在乎的东西。我们从未真正住在那里。我们住在彼此的身边。
And when my mom read my first draft of this, she said that I shouldn't end it this way because it's glib, and defeatist, and seems to absolve my great grandfather for his political inaction. But it's not like anybody's going to read this stupid essay anyway. And even if they do, it'll eventually be lost like everything else, besides Spider-Man. So I'm just going to stop it right here. Because I want to go out and the night's still young.
当我妈妈读到这份草稿时，她说我不应该这样结尾，因为它轻率、宿命论，而且似乎赦免了我曾祖父的政治不作为。但好像也没人会看这篇愚蠢的文章。即使有人看，它最终也会像其他所有东西一样丢失，除了《蜘蛛侠》。所以我打算就在这里停下。因为我想出去，夜还长着呢。
Simon Rich reading a short story, "History Report." His most recent collection of short stories is called New Teeth.
Simon Rich朗读短篇小说，“历史报告”。他最近的一部短篇小说集名为《新牙》（New Teeth）。
["I LOVE MY DAD" BY SUN KIL MOON]
Well, our program was produced today by our show's senior editor David Kestenbaum with James Bennett II. The people who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Chris Benderev, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Micky Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Ike Sriskandarajah, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由高级编辑David Kestenbaum和James Bennett II制作。今天制作节目的人员包括Bim Adewunmi、Chris Benderev、Jendayi Bonds、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Micky Meek、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Ike Sriskandarajah、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney、Julie Whitaker和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Nicole Wolf Rodriguez-Robbins, Tarek Fouda, Mark Johnson of Global Wildlife Resources, David Mech of the US Geological Survey and the University of Minnesota, and Bill White.
我们的总编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。特别感谢今天的Nicole Wolf Rodriguez-Robbins、Tarek Fouda、全球野生动物资源中心的Mark Johnson、美国地质调查局和明尼苏达大学的David Mech以及Bill White。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's merch for your holiday shopping needs, list of favorite shows, tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费流媒体收听我们超过800集的存档。还有满足你节日购物需求的周边商品，最喜爱节目的列表，以及海量其他内容。再次申明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX传送至公共电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He was helping his little nephew with a school project, this 3D topographical map of the Ottoman Empire, which was very nice until he called the kid's teacher to brag--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他当时正在帮助小侄子完成一项学校作业，这个奥斯曼帝国的3D地形图，一直都很棒，直到他打电话给那个孩子的老师炫耀——
I said I was very involved in putting that little turkey together.
我说我参与了组装那个小东西的过程。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
["I LOVE MY DAD" BY SUN KIL MOON]